well after the state of New York no
state in the country has been hit harder
by this virus than the state of New
Jersey as of today New Jersey has more
than 71 thousand cases of it more than
3,100 people have died so far since the
21st of March all residents in the state
have been under a stay at home order and
that's had a big predictable economic
effect in the past month 577 thousand
New Jerseyans have filed for
unemployment Phil Murphy is the governor
of New Jersey says that for now the
shutdown will continue he joins us now
governor we really appreciate your
coming on tonight thank you very much I
know you've got a lot to deal with
and and I and I want to say at the
outset that I and I mean this sincerely
I always presume good faith in the
decisions that our leaders are making
right now because I know it's complex
especially for you the most dense state
in the country second highest death toll
but there's a couple of things that I
find confusing and I'd love to hear them
explain the first is the rationale for
the lockdown
now you said early on the point was the
most governor said this was to flatten
the curve to spread out the infection so
our health care system didn't collapse
it didn't collapse it would came close
but it didn't now today in your press
conference you gave a different
rationale for the lockdown and you said
that you can't foresee normal gatherings
continue and I think it's a quote until
essentially there are no more cases why
the change again it's good to be on with
you we believe completely that we don't
get a economic recovery unless we've got
a complete or near complete health care
recovery so flattening that curve
reduces the amount of hospitalizations
reduces the amount of intensive care
beds ventilators health care workers
needed etc and so you want to get the
line to cross between that and your
capacity if we have let this go we think
three plus million New Jerseyans would
have been infected the number thank god
is going to be a lot less than that
Tucker but we're still not out of the
woods yet my comments today were
directed at things like high school
graduations religious gatherings that
folks had asked me about for June and I
just I can't say with confidence I think
April the next couple of weeks
is
to be our toughest period may I hope
please God assuming folks stay home
we'll be a little bit better I can't
predict with certainty into the summer
so my rationale is the same I just got
to make sure that I'm being straight
with people about the timing and frankly
what we don't know yet but this standard
that we're not going to have these large
gatherings including as you said
religious services or NFL games which
you have in your state until we're
basically at 0 new infections that's not
a standard that we apply to any other
infectious diseases including diseases
that kill you know as many people as
this is projected to kill so why the
different standard in this case yeah I
wouldn't say it's a different standard
and maybe it's the way I said it today
but here is here's the reality you get
that economic recovery that responsible
reopening after you've cracked the back
of this I don't think any of us can
expect that we can get this to zero
particularly in the absence of a vaccine
and it sounds like that's a year a year
and a half away but I do think and I did
say this today and we believe this
strongly that we need a much broader
testing regime and that will give us
confidence if we can quickly test folks
Rutgers University our state university
by the way started this week with the
saliva test which they think could be
scaled up dramatically that would give
us an enormous amount of confidence to
be able to say you know what we could
get back on our feet again and we can we
can highlight where there might be a
burgeoning hotspot have contact tracing
in place and keep a lid on this right
and at the same time let let us get back
on our feet
that'll be hugely important I think for
every state once you get large
randomized tests in the state of New
Jersey what do you expect the death rate
will turn out to be from this disease
well I don't know Tucker I based on
everything we've seen it is meaningfully
higher than the the urine and year-out
influenza of course influenza there are
vaccines for that I get a flu shot every
year and please God we have a fresh shot
soon for this as well I don't have a I
don't have a specific answer other than
it appears to be higher and part of the
reason is we know the folks who have
passed and there been far too many in
our state over
three thousand blessed souls as you said
the denominator is the tough thing to
get our arms around right now and that's
in the absence of the universal testing
that we desperately need that's right
so you just compared it to the annual
influenza so there is a vaccine
typically for that the new IHM ii
numbers University of Washington model
that I think most of our leaders have
been referring to suggests about 60,000
deaths nationwide by August 4th that
would be fewer than what the annual
influenza caused a couple of years ago
with a vaccine so does that shake your
faith at all in the utility of a vaccine
for this disease maybe it's not the
final answer yeah it doesn't shake my
faith in either the vaccine which all
experts think is at least a year a year
and a half away it does tell me that if
the death tolls are around the numbers
that you've just referred to Tucker that
all of the actions were taking or making
a difference I really believe that with
all my heart the fact that we're staying
at home staying away from each other is
flattening the curve is leading
eventually we've got too many lost souls
believe me every one of them is a
precious life but the fact that it may
be larger than we had expected means
that it's working let me ask you about
the specific measures she just referred
to now large gatherings are banned but
liquor stores are deemed an essential
service why on the basis of what
scientific evidence did you decide that
a couple of things one is there are
liquor stores in our state that actually
have a little bit too many backroom
gatherings so we had a little bit of a
challenge we had to remind folks that
liquor stores may be opening but may be
open but to your point gatherings are
not allowed we relied on a whole lot of
input reasonable input from recovery
coaches addiction coaches and they
caution does if we were to shut up
shutter those stores down we'd have
unintended mental health and addiction
prices to pay unintended consequences
and so far that's the route
we've taken and my guesses will continue
to take that route so but you have
closed church services and synagogue
services and arrested people for
attempting to attend them did anyone say
that maybe practicing your faith might
be important to someone's mental health
listen I think we've had a very good
good common ground with faith leaders of
literally every faith you'll understand
this and by the way whether it's a
liquor store
a pharmacy a supermarket we expect folks
to distance themselves from each other
to wear face coverings etc there's an
enormous amount going on virtually right
now a lot of practicing going on and we
care deeply about both physical health
and mental health of course but I just
and I don't want to be too persistent on
this but I think it's important on what
scientific basis did you decide that
sitting in a church was much more
dangerous than buying liquor in a liquor
store and why is buying liquor more
important for the social Fatma I'm just
what I'm just trying to think you're not
the only governor has done this and I
don't mean to pick on you but it I don't
understand the reasoning I don't want to
think it had anything to do with tax
revenues no it does not have anything to
do with tax revenues our revenues are so
blown up that would be a rounding error
trust me this is the either or it can be
an both I've spoken to Cardinal Tobin to
the leaders of the Jewish community of
the Muslim community people are at peace
where we have come out there no one's
happy everyone wants to get back to what
they think of as the norm and who could
blame them I want to do that as well but
I don't think these are one versus the
other I think you could have both of
these realities at the same time and
that's what we have in New Jersey right
now so why back a couple of weeks ago
you closed state parks and people have
been arrested for using them a man was
arrested for sitting alone on the beach
tell me why that poses a danger again on
what scientific basis did you make that
decision
yes so so Tucker we were coming into
both warm weather and big religious
seasons it was Passover first then
Easter we've got Ramadan coming up
shortly in certain of the counties were
beginning to close their parks and the
concern was that the folks who couldn't
go to their normal park would go to
another park in another county or a
state park and it wasn't just a gut feel
we then surveilled the state up and down
the state on that first weekend of April
well we had some good weather in New
Jersey and in fact that was just what we
saw lots of people congregating lots of
out-of-state license plates so it was a
step trust me I took no joy in taking
that step but it's one that we felt we
had okay but on what basis that what
scientists because we're we're I'm just
trying to get to the science here
because I assume all of us are following
the lead of epidemiologists arresting
someone for sitting alone on the beach
tell me how that arrests the spread of
the corona virus from an epidemiological
point of view yeah I wasn't referring to
that I actually don't have the specifics
as to why that happened I meant
congregation at state and county parks
of which there was an enormous amount
when that the weather got warm and the
fact that folks weren't it's not that
they couldn't be in the park and jogging
by themselves or walking on their own
and keeping distance they weren't and
there were a lot of out-of-state license
plates in the parking lots and and we've
got some of the nicest parts of the
Northeast if not the country again it
brings me no joy but we felt that was
the right decision to make so you made
that decision and as I noted before 15
congregants at a synagogue in New Jersey
were arrested and charged for being in a
synagogue together now the Bill of
Rights as you well know protects
Americans right in shrines their right
to practice their religion as they see
fit and to congregate together to
assemble peacefully by what authority
did unify the Bill of Rights in issuing
this order how do you have the power we
were that
that's above my paygrade Tucker so I
wasn't I wasn't thinking of the Bill of
Rights when we did this we went to all
first of all we looked at the day again
it's a science and it says B people have
to stay away from each other that's the
best thing we could do to break the back
of the curve of this virus that leads to
lower hospitalizations and ultimately
I'm not though I think it's I do I do
think there's a debate this is a rolling
rolling conversation because we're
learning new things every day and
nothing is settled it there's no
interested but I do want since you are
since you are an elected official a
leader in the government an executive
how do you have the authority to order
something that so clearly contravenes
the Bill of Rights of the United States
the US Constitution where do you get the
authority to do that well here's here's
the thing we know we need to stay away
from each other number one number two we
do have broad authority within the state
and number three we would never do that
without coordinating discussing and
hashing it out with the leaders the the
variety of the leaders of the face of
New Jersey we have we are among if not
the most that you be talked to every
rabbi and priest but but there's a
deeper question here and I I'm just
gonna ask you one last time because I
think it's important I'm sure you've
thought about this
you can't just as the governor of a
state tell people who they can talk to
when and where because the Constitution
of the United States upon which all of
this is based prohibits you from doing
that so you clearly decided that you
could do it did you consult an attorney
about this did you I mean because
there's a this is a legal question as
well as an as a medical one isn't it i I
don't go to the men's room without
consulting an attorney so I guarantee
you we write that but I'll give you an
example that was not related in the
synagogue I called up Cardinal Tobin
Cardinal Joe Tobin in Newark there are
five or six archdiocese in New Jersey
was coming up to Easter and Holy Week in
particular and I said listen I'm really
concerned about drive-through Holy
Communion because we had heard some
stories about priests who unwittingly
had the virus and unwittingly passed it
on to parishioners and he said we're not
on that I promise you and I'll confirm
that with my fellow bishops that's not
denying someone their right to worship
and in any way that we have to find a
different way to worship I think that's
the point god bless america
we're not governments to tell people how
to worship engine just as a sort of
factual learn last question since your
question so these orders which again I'm
presuming and I believe were taken in
good faith under trying circumstances
have nevertheless and you just said it
have resulted in an awful lot of
suffering five hundred seventy seven
thousand New Jerseyans on unemployment
doubtless the suicide rate will increase
the addiction rate will increase liquor
stores are open as we noted are you how
much does that weigh on you that the
suffering that this lockdown has caused
might equal or perhaps outweigh what the
virus does do you think about that
it weighs heavily and you ask yourself
every day are you making the right
decision and the answer is this a
twofold Tucker one is we continue to
make every call based on the facts the
data the science as best we can and
secondly I look at what we're doing
versus the alternative and I know that
the alternative had we had we step back
and let this virus run amok three plus
million people in our state would have
been infected in the health care system
that had note would have had no chance
to have kept up with that of the
fatalities would have been multiple so
each life lost is a precious life loss
let there be no doubt about it but the
alternative would have been multiples of
this as it relates to economic suffering
if it had been millions it would have
been a lot worse
it would have been down the road we
chose to rip the band-aid off and deal
with this up front and God willing we've
made the right set of decisions best of
luck governor thanks for joining us
tonight appreciate it thanks for having
me Tucker